[Musique]
notre relation fondamentale
nous sommes tous la convention
[Musique]
les gens ordinaires peuvent faire des
choses extraordinaires
[Musique]
je crois que j'étais bien cerner tu as
grandi dans le kansas et maman de
cuisine et de bonnes petites tartes aux
pommes salut tout le monde je vous
présente dany d'amis bienvenue à new
york
[Musique]
surtout n'utilise pas ton prénom la
mafia gère cette boîte une association
qui lutte pour les droits des
homosexuels
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que tu regardes tu as finale
hall et ses dessins roulement entre le
maire c'est contre ça qu'on se permet
pas la regarder moi bordel nous devons
nous battre
racine et résister au radicalisme que je
voie d'être dans certains quartiers
je n'ai vu aucun rêve se réaliser sur
christopher street montsoult gpat chez
moi j'ai pu être famille
comment
ces courses là non plus rien à perdre
je peux pas téméraire
pas comme saâdane et c'est la seule
façon
on organise une marche en commémoration
des émeutes
la marche de libération des homos
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
puis 12